بالفعل معارك شرسه وداريه تستعر خلال ال
24 ساعه الماضيه وحتى هذه اللحظه منذ
الصباح الباكر لم تتوقف اصوات المدافع
والصواريخ التي تطلق وتسقط في ذات الحين
ذلك لان يوم امس
اعتبر ذكرى اطلاق اول رصاصه للانفصاليين
في الثاني عشر من ابريل نيسان من عام 2014
ذلك ما جعل يعني رفع وتيره الاعمال
العسكريه من قبل الطرفين الاوكراني
روسي هاجس كبير من اجل تكريس ذكرى هذا
اليوم وهو ذكرى الانفصال
يعني للانفصاليين عن اوكرانيا
باخمت معركه باخمت هي الاكثر سخونه حتى
الان 24 ساعه الماضيه شهدت معارك ضاريه
وشرسه بالفعل خاصه في وسط المدينه
الى منطقه سكك الحديديه وسيطرت على اجزاء
من المحطات منها محطه باخموت اثنان كما
انها سيطرت على صوامع الحبوب في المنطقه
الغربيه من المدينه تتقدم قوات فاجنر الى
المنطقه الغربيه التي كانت تعتبر محرمه
على القوات الروسيه لتمركز القوات
الاوكرانيه فيها كما انها سيطرت على عده
شوارع اهمها الشارع الرئيسي وهو التاسع من
مايو بالفعل هناك تقدم حسب المعلومات
الرسميه التي اعلن عنها مستشار القائم
باعمال الرئاسه هنا في دانيسك لقوات فاجنر
في محور باقمت بعد ان سيطرت كما اسلفت على
80% من الارض مقاومه شرسه ايضا من الجانب
الاوكراني المقاتلات الروسيه نفذت تسع
غارات جويه ضربت فيها قواعد عسكريه
اوكرانيه في محاور مختلفه اهم المحور
الجنوبي والشرق ي كما ان المعارك مستعره
في مدن اخرى هناك قصف شديد بالفعل فاطمه
لا نعلم اذا كان قريب من وسط المدينه
هناك معارك في مدن اخرى اهمها
يعني ايضا ارتفاع
هل ادى ربما الى تخفيف الضغط وتخفيف
التركيز على المناطق الاخرى في الشرق
الاوكراني
بالعكس ارتفعت وتيره الاعمال العسكريه في
كل منطقه على حده لا بد من ان نعرف
المشاهد بان طريقه عمل الجيش الروسي
مختلفه نوعا ما عن الجيش الاوكراني الذي
يعتبر جيش بوحد روسيا هي اتحاد روسيا
وفيدرالي فلذلك تعمل قوات فاغنر على سبيل
المثال في محور باخمه بينما عملت القوات
الشيشانيه في محور مدينه ماريوبل هناك
مدينه افديفيكا يتسلم المهام العسكريه في
مدينه افديفيكا
مقاتلي جمهوريه ابخازيا
هي التي انفصلت عن جورجيا قبل اكثر من
عشره سنوات
والمقاتلين
هم الذين ينفذون عمليات اقتحام مستمره في
مدينه ارتفعت العمليات العسكريه هناك ايضا
خلال ال 24 ساعه الماضيه وشهدت ايضا غارات
لسلاح الجو الروسي في
لم تسجل اي دخول الى المدينه هناك محاولات
فعليه للسيطره ولو على جزء بسيط
ليعتبر تقدم للجيش الروسي في مدينه
افديفكا بينما سجلت القوات الروسيه او
القوات المتطوعه الروسيه في مدينه مارينكا
المتاخمه لافديفكا سيطر على احد الاحياء
في المنطقه الغربيه وهو تطور لم يحدث منذ
عده اشهر حيث كان هناك
يعني فطور او عدم تقدم للقوات الروسيه بعد
ان سيطرت على ثلثي مدينه مارينكا سيطرت
على حي
فادينو في المنطقه الغربيه بينما يعتبر
المحور الجنوبي وهو محور مدينه اوغلادار
ساكنا نوعا ما وهناك يعني انتظار او ترقب
لعوده اوكرانيه حيث هناك تسريبات بان
الجيش الاوكراني يحشد للعوده على المدن
القريبه من مدينه اوغلادا في ذلك المحور
لمتابعه
المزيد لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على
اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات